[MUSIC]
If you think about the speed
at which a crisis develops,
far faster than it ever did before, and
so you may not have all
the information you would like.
You may not know all the facts and
that might lead you to not respond.
There's a natural tendency, well,
we don't have all the facts so
we can't really say anything.
Well, what you can say
is what your values are.
And what you can talk about your values,
and
that whatever you do in response to a
particular crisis is going to be based on
the values of your organization or
your company.
Companies that don't really have
clarity about their values and
are kind of coming up with them on the
fly, they're at a tremendous disadvantage.
Conversely, companies that have
a very clear sense of who they are,
what they stand for, even in the midst of
crisis, they have competitive advantage.
[MUSIC]